as of now up to
2.25 that decision just coming in uh
literally just a minute or two ago
um it is a bit if I'm being honest with
you of a surprise a lot of people had
expected the bank to go even further
than that to raise interest rates by
0.75 so going up by half of a percentage
point it's certainly big you know it's
equal to the biggest they've done before
which was in August uh and a few times
in the 1990s it takes it up to the
highest level that we've seen since I
think 2008 but even so it's not going as
far as many people had expected and I
just wonder whether that's something
that will raise question marks both in
government so obviously we've had Liz
truss and quasi quote and asking
questions about whether the bank of
England has is doing enough to clamp
down on inflation and that really is the
backdrop for all of this remember
inflation currently at 9.9 but expected
to go even higher in the coming months
but also when you look at what's
happening in markets right now when you
look at the strength of the pound and
you know this is an institution which is
the home of the pound it is it is
basically their job to keep the pound uh
as stable as possible well when you well
I should say they're not really
targeting currencies but they are kind
of you know in control uh of the the
pound when do you have the pound falling
as much as it has done recently that has
raised more than eyebrows uh here in
thread needle streets so the fact that
they haven't raised interest rates quite
as much as expected you've got to look
at Cold currency markets and potentially
see an impact from that in terms of the
background to the decision it was a 5-4
decision they've got nine members on the
Montreal policy committee five of them
voted to raise interest rates by 0.5 so
it was a split decision it was a close
decision uh it could well have been more
but it's worth just saying you know a
lot of people expected the banks to go
further than even this the big picture
here though is on the other side of town
here in London on the other side in
Westminster you have the government
committing to a very big very big
increases in spending in borrowing and
when and that happens all else equal
that's the kind of thing that forces the
bank of England or whoever setting
interest rates to push them higher and
that's basically what's happening only a
few months ago the expectation in
markets was the interest rates were only
going to get up to about kind of 2.25
where they are as of now now when you
look at what people are betting on they
expect interest rates to get all the way
up to 4.75 so nearly five percent so
this is big stuff it is a major shift on
where we were only a few months ago part
of it is down to high inflation part of
it is down to the government spending a
lot more money and obviously we'll learn
how much more money uh potentially
tomorrow at least what the extra
measures are going to be and as a result
of that the bank of England is taking
action but as I say not quite as much
action not quite as dramatic as some had
expected 0.5 increase very big by recent
historical standards uh but not quite as
far as many people in the markets might
have expected and Ed my understanding is
they're not meeting next month so this
this has now got to tide us over to over
a two-month period when they do next
meet does that suggest then that it
could go up again quite quickly at the
next meeting
it could it could well do I mean
remember what tends to happen is that
they don't have a meeting every single
month at the moment uh they they have
meetings some of which uh happen like
today without producing a set of new
forecasts so we've got some signals on
what they expect to happen with the
economy but we don't have a full new
forecast some of them do and that's the
next meeting in November is going to be
with a full forecast and the broad
expectation is you're going to see
another big increase in interest rates
then as I say when you look at what
people Traders in the market are
expecting they're expecting rates to get
up to 4.75 and I know that's not big by
historical standards but given that we
have a higher debt load at the moment
given that people's earnings in
comparison to their house prices and to
their mortgages are lower than they were
in many previous years that is really
very high it's about the highest level
that we've seen before a few of the last
recent house price crashes so this is
serious and it is going up very fast and
part of that is because inflation is
very high right now like I say part of
it is because when the government spends
more money when it borrows more or all
else equal you would expect an
institution like the bank of England to
raise interest rates and that is what
they're doing